the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler all your social
media and as I say every week thank you
thank you for watching this show thank
you for supporting the show Please
Subscribe tell everybody about it it's
the free way to help the show all right
if you gotta have more then you gotta
check out the patreon the patreon is
called the Honeydew with y'all and I do
the same thing with y'all and y'all got
the wildest stories of Ever we just had
a guy on who uh his his parachute didn't
open and homeboy hit the ground and
lived we had an old aunt and uncle get
taken hostage and the uncle got away got
a gun and subscribe and you'll hear how
the rest of that goes it's five bucks a
month that's it there's no tears no
levels if you sign up for a year you get
like a month of episodes for free you
get the Honeydew a day early you get it
ad free at no additional cost all right
and if you were someone you know has a
story that has to be heard please submit
it the Honeydew podcast gmail.com all
right uh thank you guys for supporting
the special Lefty son it's up there go
watch it share it comment on it and if
you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to I'm telling you go listen to
my old podcast that I used to do with
Jay Larson called The Crab Feast it's
every single person you know and love in
podcasting Tom segor Burt crazier
Christina P they're all on there with
different stories it's a great fun
podcast all right August 18th and 19th
I'm in Tampa Steve Simone will be
joining me for that September 1st and
2nd Springfield Missouri September 15th
and 16th we're in Tulsa and September
29th and 30th is Phoenix October 27 28th
Salt Lake City and December 8th and 9th
San Francisco California all right all
your tickets are at ryansickler.com now
that's the biz and you guys know what
we're doing over here
we're highlighting the low lights all
right I always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers and I'm very
excited to have this guest on here first
time on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Jim Gaffigan
welcome to the Honeydew Jim Gaff thank
you so much bring you in strong gym guys
that was that was a good one you don't
even know dude uh first before we even
get into everything we're gonna talk
about please plug promote everything and
anything Jim Gaffigan that you'd like
and I know there's a lot
well I mean I guess uh you know I have
this new uh Amazon special that is
uh begins streaming on July 25th it's my
10th comedy special
amazing right I'm not an old man that's
nuts 10. yeah right isn't that crazy and
then I uh have uh I'm on tour this fall
uh with the barely alive tour which is
different material than than that and
then I'm alive and Alive tour you're the
barely alive
um and then uh
um in this new Max uh mini series called
Full Circle
which uh and I get to play a Postal
Inspector and I uh it's it's a Steven
Soderberg show so it's good stuff and
zazi beats and uh Claire Danes and
Timothy Oliphant and uh
um
um I can't think of some of the other
names but and then I'm doing some dates
this fall with
uh young comedian named uh Jerry
Seinfeld oh yeah that kid so I heard
good things about it doing Chicago San
Francisco St Louis and LA
but I'm excited to be here you know what
I mean it's like
I feel like I'm meeting the mayor of of
Maryland
well I said to you like so first of all
I'm a huge huge fan and I'm like Beyond
respectful and I I like I pay attention
to the game and I I had released a
comedy album out and for a hot second it
bumped you down to like number two for
10 seconds and and you started following
me on Twitter and I was like Wow Jim
Gaffigan followed me and then
the night that I met you at the comedy
store which has been a second now
um they'd say gaffigans come on I'm like
oh my God I love Jim Gavin I
can't wait and you come through the back
and I have been standing out the doorway
on Sunset smoking a joint I was not
expecting you to be there that quickly
and when you come through I was like hey
Jim I'm Ryan I shake your hand you're
like oh you're from Baltimore right and
I was floored by that but also I felt so
self-conscious and terrible because I
blew weed smoke all over Jim Gaffigan's
this is my first meeting you know what I
mean I'm like oh my God then we go back
we talk we hang out you tell me a great
day to tell joke that I still repeat do
you remember it no no um do you want to
tell it will you tell her I tell you
it's the Hitler and the hollow at the
Halloween party that is amazing so
um there's a guy who's throwing a
Halloween party right and everyone's
hanging hanging out having a great time
they're drinking dancing partying it's a
good time the dudes going around making
sure he's like oh great great great and
then crossed away he sees a guy who
looks identically like Adolf Hitler he's
dressed like Hitler hits this guy doing
at my Halloween party dress like Hitler
so he goes over to to say something he's
like hey man you can't uh you can't wear
that here you can't be here like that
and he's like what if I tell you that
I'm actually Adolf Hitler and I've
returned to kill 10 000 Jews six million
more Jews six million more Jews and
three and three clowns okay I'm gonna
change it up what if I'm here to tell
you I'm here to kill six more million
more Jews and three clowns and he's like
what he goes I'm actually Adolf Hitler
I'm back from the dead I'm here to kill
six mil million more Jews and three
clowns and the guy goes why three clowns
and Hitler's like see no one gives a
about the juice
ah
it's dude unbelievable I tell everybody
I'm like Jim Gaffigan is telling me a
Dave Attell joke like that you're like
David tell told me I'm like Jesus even
better right so such a great time
meeting you and then my brother's like
I'm pretty sure I've seen him in church
in Maryland I'm like I don't think so I
don't know maybe maybe his wife and that
you're telling me before we start
recording you actually do have people
there yeah no my uh
my mom's family is from Iowa but my
grandfather got a job
in DC
and he uh so my aunt lived in in
Maryland she lived on the Eastern Shore
for years and uh so I've been going to
Maryland every summer for like
I don't know my entire life for like a
week or and you know eating you know
like the crabs and the and the you know
like there's so many it's Maryland is so
such a unique microcosm uh in itself
right it is and so it's a little tiny
State that's got all these things
mountains a dangerous city yeah the bay
the ocean the crabs the seafood it's you
know it was like a border state but it
really wasn't a border state yes you
know the fact you say y'all you know
it's it's Southern right and then and
um but so there's the family connection
but also
uh you know when my wife and I started
having kids we ended up meeting this
other couple
that ended up because I have five kids
and so this other couple ended up having
five kids and the husband
is from Maryland it's from Baltimore too
so that would so we ended up the
Maryland connection was so consistent
and then uh you know and it's just the
proximity yeah I mean it's not far it's
the start of the uh the you know I call
the Northwest the Northeast Corridor
that Acela line I call that the corridor
of hate because everyone is so angry on
that line right so it's it's kind of
it's in how many fights I've been in the
state of Maryland it's an angry place oh
my gosh I remember one time we were on
the Eastern Shore and
my wife and and our friend the the wife
of my friend were in the bathroom and it
was we're in this bar that was kind of
empty and this woman came in and tried
to start a fist fight with them it's
like these are you know the mothers of
five children it was not a CD box
yeah it was just this woman was on a
tear but it's the whole Northeast is
like that you know in Boston yeah yeah
you know like I remember one time I was
in Nantucket and uh for some festival
thing and my wife and I were in a bar
and we're like this is very preppy and I
was like what's that Bell for and
they're like well and there's a fight we
ring the bell so the the bouncers know
to come in and I'm looking around and
it's all just rich people in preppy
outfits and I'm like how often
and there's just these these guys in
like these Nantucket pink
and you're like what is going on
what is Corridor of hate right yeah it's
such a great name although at Philly
yeah
all the way up you're not all the way up
yeah you know New Haven it's just it's
just combat yeah Providence yeah so um
tell me about your upbringing you're
from Indiana originally that's where
you're born and raised too or was born
in Illinois but we moved to Indiana
uh when I was in
um the middle of fifth grade my dad got
fired and he got a job
uh in Indiana what was he doing in
Illinois he was a banker he was I think
he I think he kind of told his boss to
off oh yeah
and you know now you do that and people
like ah you know you shouldn't do that
and back then people were like you're
gone
and so but I think he didn't get a
promotion and he was really pissed and
so he got a different job in Northwest
Indiana and Northwest Indiana it's like
hard to describe
it is I mean I have such affinity for
Northwest Indiana but it is the
stepchild of Chicago like people I used
to have a joke when I would perform in
Chicago
where people in you tell someone from
Chicago because it it goes Chicago and
then Northwest Indiana is right there
and if you said hey I'm from Northwest
Indiana people in Chicago would be like
where's that you're like it's 10 it's 15
minutes away yeah but it was such kind
of like the area of riffraff and also
like when I would do shows in Chicago I
could always tell when there were people
from Northwest Indiana because I do meet
and greets after the show and they would
be in sweatpants it would be like
Saturday night and they're like showing
up in sweatpants but they're good sweats
they're good they're good they're like
you know this I'm not at work ah yeah
I'm going to a show yeah but um so I
grew up I I identify as someone from
Northwest Indiana which is which is the
Calumet region which is different from
real Indiana like people think of real
Indiana as
uh you know the whole it's it's so like
Northwest Indiana is kind of a a mix of
a lot of you know Gary African-American
City ethnocentric uh I mean ethnic
Catholics you know
uh Eastern European you know Mexican and
so I had moved from Chicago which was
kind of the uh this Lily white suburb of
Chicago to Northwest Indiana so it was
culture shock and it was pretty brutal
it was a pretty rude awakening like I
think I was like the strongest kid in
fifth grade and then I arrived and I was
like nothing
and so that's where I think I really I
had your sixth grade basically your
middle school years you start in Indiana
yeah in the middle of fifth grade and I
had some jokes that we you know had you
know you learn as little kids so that
was
I was trying to get an adjective before
pale you know what I mean so it was like
the funny pale kid right right you know
that new pale kid
you know so it's that new real white kid
an adjective I always say when they're
that white they're white you gotta hit
the H on that like yeah it's white yeah
and so it was uh it was a it was
strangely
uh uh informative to how my
my whole life would go so it's like
that's where I really felt like an
outsider ironically you know obviously
compared to like someone who's truly
been like oppressed it's nothing but
like I was uh so I had to develop kind
of I had always been funny but like
comedy was a tool to kind of gain uh
approval I had used it for you know
being the youngest of six kids to kind
of because it was just combat for food
when I was growing up you know I mean
like my parents
were there but it was just it was not
like what we see today it was you know
like I know where my kids are at all
times I know when they're sporting
things are happening and specifically
versus like oh they're out they're out
playing versus like yeah the see you at
six pm yeah yeah I mean uh you ever deal
with the parents I don't mean interrupt
you but this trips me out once I had a
kid I started realizing there's
different styles of parenting like I
remember going to a three-year-old's
birthday party we're taking our daughter
to this three year olds birthday party
and some of the parents just show up and
they just leave their kid like
what time you want me back four all
right and they leave and I'm like wait
we can do that you know what I mean like
yeah just bait you're using this as a
babysitter right now yeah well wow and
the point is that they're three yeah
it's not
eight or nine it's like
well that's you know you got kids it's
like the the other parents that is
that is you know that's one of the
catastrophes of being a parent is the
other parents they're just they don't
care yeah you know they don't care or
they care too much so by comparison
you're the worst parent ever right I see
that guy leaving I'm like I ain't doing
so bad you know yeah I would eat some
Little Caesars I'm pretty good
okay so you're using comedy to sort of
ingratiate yourself in this uh new
community yes and then and are your
parents um together at this point yes
everyone's together all eight of you
then yes okay and you know but it was
definitely uh there's there's conflict
and you know I'm the youngest of six and
my different siblings are reacting
differently to this move like definitely
the move it's so interesting because
when we walked in you're describing the
premise I didn't I didn't realize
that uh it was such a a life-altering
thing for me and my siblings this move
because it was a culture shift
and uh and it was just kind of like fat
you know it's one thing defend for your
own when you were raised there and you
knew every neighbor but like when you're
kind of thrown in there
and uh it was a different thing and I I
think my mom was miserable uh initially
so it was that was traumatic I'm
surprised to hear to you so I know about
Gary Indiana but I didn't know about
Eastern Europeans oh yeah I didn't know
about even a Mexican
um
oh yeah culture being there as well well
yeah but are a lot of them trickling
down out of Chicago a lot of people too
yes some of them but it's some of it is
you know like the Rust Belt if you
consider
like Detroit is where all the cars were
made and you know Pennsylvania was where
all the steel was made and then but like
Northwest India like Gary was like the
first of the Rust Belt to die like
supposedly Gary in 1938 was considered
the most beautiful city in the world
world yes I think it was in Time
Magazine and so
Gary was Gary like white flight had been
so immediate and dramatic and it was so
overshadowed by the collapse of the
steel mill industry and the automotive
industry and people had left you know so
like that people had kind of like people
would literally drive through they would
drive from Chicago through the Indiana
part where I'm from to get to Michigan
because Michigan was beautiful and uh
people had their summer houses there but
like where I'm from Northwest Indiana
was this strange uh step child that was
not accepted by Indiana and not accepted
by Chicago so it was it was a weird
thing to kind of I think it affected
everyone that lived in Northwest Indiana
so who or are both of your parents very
Catholic was it Dad Mom
well my dad you know my dad was the
first one to go to college in his family
and he was uh and I you know if I
understand this correctly so like it
used to be you would
if you were a kid uh a poor kid or
whatever you would go into the Seminary
like he almost became a priest but I
think I realized later on that you go
into the Seminary so that you can get
free higher education and so he went
into the Seminary
got uh you know
a free education and then then switched
then went to college but it's weird it's
like it's kind of I mean but you know
Maryland is like was created as this
state for Catholics like they're like
let's stick on the Catholic yeah let's
stick all the Catholics there it's
Maryland they're obsessed with Mary yeah
I mean we'll call it Mary land and all
the Catholics are like oh let's go let's
go there and Lord Baltimore was
I think he was it was all it might have
been I should know this because it's
interesting but it was kind of his whole
idea I think and I think also the Jews
went there too because they were like is
a big Jewish population where like we
don't have to deal with
uh you know the these because you know
by the way and I did that finding my
roots thing both sides of my family
were and to to answer your question
neither of my parents were that Catholic
like my dad was kind of a Sim you know
it was kind of a way to get out of
Springfield Illinois and then my mom was
kind of a cultural Catholic but both
sides of my family when they did this
finding the roots like one of them my
mom's side of the family settled in
Maine and then during the know-nothings
where they would literally uh just kind
of hunt down Catholic priests and kill
them
they were they kind of fleed to the most
western part of where settlers had been
which was Iowa so my mom's from Iowa and
then eventually her dad got a job in DC
but my dad's side
they uh came from Ireland and they
worked in steel mill I worked in coal
mines in Pennsylvania and then they
worked in coal mines in Springfield
Illinois
and so it was generation and generation
of working in coal mines and my
grandfather was the one that kind of
broke it by making Dentures so is that
what he did in DC no but that's so
that's my mom's side of the family they
had when they went to Iowa I think they
like opened a store or something but
it's just so weird that like Iowa was
the Western frontier at one point it's
just bananas
as far as anyone got it's like also you
know they could have gone they probably
could have gone to Maryland
but they didn't you know so I don't know
so
um your dad sort of used the Seminary
the way some people use the military
then absolutely education all that yeah
and then said I'm out of here and I'm
definitely gonna have sex and I'm gonna
have six kids yeah I'm gonna have six
kids yeah and uh but he was uh
it's weird you know like the the era of
my parents being I mean the the Catholic
churches understandably been decimated
but during the 50s
there was the most important person in a
small town
was not the mayor it was particularly if
it was a Catholic Community it was the
priest right so like you literally are
kind of
you you know you're you never have to
pay for a meal like it's like you the
the the appeal of being a priest which
is so uh understandably tinged was it
was the most highest status position you
could have in a community it's so weird
how that picture I have out there the
old Baltimore Colts all kneeling down
before a game has the priest in there
with them before they go out you know
you got the priest you think about the
Rocky movie before he goes to drive to
his fight he pulls over and he yells up
to the father and he's throwing some
blessings out the window before he heads
off yeah it's so interesting it's uh but
so yeah so I would say but when I was
thinking about
you know pivotal moments in uh probably
the biggest you know like I think I lost
my dog when I was 13.
uh you know we think
the neighbor was dealing with like
raccoons and so they put poison out
but we don't know you know some of it is
dogs just eventually die it's tragic
what kind of dog was this he was like a
mutt you know uh what was his name
buttons yeah and he smelled horrible but
he was
but that was like the first thing in my
life that had been uh
this look I was in shock I was like a
mess and you know my siblings were kind
of like
it was interesting because they dealt
with it differently
I think they were I was a sensitive
child no but it was uh
it's weird you know it's like in some
ways it's like I probably didn't process
it that well but I remember being caught
off guard by it but when I was in my
so I grew up in this family that was my
father was the first one to go to
college
the uh you know it took us
tons of generations to get to the middle
class upper middle class so the concept
of
you sought security and security was
wearing a tie to work and so
and I was the youngest in All My
Siblings had kind of studied you know uh
Spanish terrorism and uh you know just
ridiculous and so by the time I was
getting ready for college my dad was
like you're studying Finance or
accounting and I was like yes sir you
know I mean like I just would I had been
very compliant and
I played football my brother but I
mainly played football because my Irish
twin brother who's kind of you have a
twin well no he's like Irish maybe you
know 15 months older than me and you
know we just were dressed identical for
the first 12 years of Our Lives
and he um
but he was the athlete but I just kind
of went along so in other words I always
had this attitude oh you want me to do
this I would just listen and so I
studied
Finance thinking no that's what you're
supposed to do that's this is it and so
and I hated it and so then when I was 24
25 my mom died and it was just like whoa
I wouldn't expect him to say that that's
young yeah and so it was
ovarian cancer and it was pretty uh
and again it was just you know one of
those things where it was
uh
you know it you know I don't think I
processed it well but what I I was
conscious of was
that the
um
the story that I had been sold or the
the life rules that I had been sold
which is
get a job with a tie
do that till you're 65 play golf and
then you you can kick it you know is
kind of a lie because she was only 53
and it was young and you know my dad was
the Boozer and you know it was like it
there was just incredible Injustice that
uh this would happen to this person so
that made me
kind of reevaluate or even I guess think
about what I wanted to do I think it's
not rare for people to just kind of go I
don't know what like they just follow
people right like often people don't
really consider like what do I want to
do like I think I remember in high
school there was a point where
I think a teacher was like you guys
should think about what you want to
study and I was like well
and I was like you know what I'm and I
thought of things I was interested in my
dad was like what are you
kidding you're not doing that and so I
mean granted my parents uh paid for
college you know in full disclosure so
it was like he did have some Authority
in it you know I mean it wasn't like I
was paying so
um
but yeah so that was the big
uh I would say that was the big life
event where I
from then on I challenged kind of
everything and I think that is
the the kind of the through line of all
comedians is kind of
challenging the acceptable notion and it
goes in different Stripes you know it
you know but that's why you know we're
all kind of conspiracy theorists you
know we're all you know highly
suspicious of
basic rules right it's so funny you say
that because
it wasn't until I asked might have been
in the last four or five years I was in
therapy and I was talking about uh I
don't know dating or whatever and she
said are you jealous and I said I'm not
I said I and she goes you're not you're
suspicious and I go that's it I
haven't been able to to throw that out
myself the whole time go that's what it
is yeah I'm suspicious of everything
I'm like I'm always it's I you know I
I've had no parents since I was 16.
and I'm very suspicious of people I'm
very suspicious of intentions very
suspicious it's not jealousy or
it's a little bit of distrust or or you
know but suspicious is the right word
yeah yeah it's just and
and by the way I mean that's kind of
necessary for developing a point of view
in comedy like you you know
I had uh you know material on Mexican
food and it's it's just you sh you know
Mexican food which is my favorite it is
you should you should be suspicious it's
essentially the same ingredients in just
a with a different name a hundred
percent you know it's refried beans like
yeah you know like it's just like
refried like it's like a burrito and a
taco it's not that different especially
if it's flour yeah yeah same thing it's
just a bigger tortilla more beautiful
it's perfect but it's just a different
name yeah you know what I mean and so uh
but that's where I think
I mean I'm so grateful that you know
doing stand up
uh that we get access to that
Jeremy because it is some of it is we
get to you know there's a communication
with the audience and
and uh you know not everyone gets it you
know I look at my kids and I'm just like
they gotta process all this stuff
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression all right it's not finding a
new therapist it's not starting a new
exercise routine it's not more in
regular meditation or a better diet
sometimes you just need to unlock your
brain a new way of thinking about and
seeing the world and maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health it's at home ketamine
therapy mind Bloom is the leader in at
home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people overcome
their anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1 200
mind Bloom clients 89 reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
a hundred dollars off your first six
session program when you sign up at my
mindbloom.com honeydew and use promo
code honeydew take the first step and
break free from your anxiety and
depression with mind Bloom mindbloom.com
honeydew and use promo code honeydew now
let's get back to the do before we start
we were talking about the haircut thing
oh yeah yeah I want to bring this up
because
in this special dark pale so like
there's been
times when I've so like we were talking
about you know you have your person you
go there every two weeks which is what
an intelligenter you what an intelligent
thoughtful person does
and I'm the kind of guy who
uh like I like when I try on shoes
people like how does it feel and I'm
like I don't know
this is my shoe size I guess they fit
and they're like you just feel your feet
I'm like I don't know and so but when I
comes to getting a haircut
because I I love acting and because I
you know I was broke uh for so long that
I got in the habit of I would wait and
get a haircut when I would get an acting
job or a commercial or something yeah
and so I would never have to pay for a
hair how long has your hair been at its
longest in between
it's you know blind my hair is look like
Ben Franklin I don't have much hair but
it was like definitely you know like
thin blonde white blonde hair it doesn't
look good in a molly
and so uh
uh I
um essentially so I never really there
might be times when I'd established a
relationship with someone cutting my
hair and in fact there is this guy who
um who's cut my hair in these Village
who's great and
um and and I used to go to him but
sometimes I call and he has of course
now he has like five businesses he has
his Barbershop he has his edible
business he's you know all this stuff
and so if I call and he's not there
I have to because I don't plan ahead I'm
like I got time for Erica hey is Ari
there no he's not all right I'll go to
this person so I went to this
um where my sons had gotten their
haircut it's this old Italian guy who
cuts hair
and it's in the East Village in
Manhattan and there's there's Italian
Americans and Italians that come to this
guy I'm like this guy's real he's a real
authentic he and so I'm like all right
great because I'm getting ready for this
special I need a haircut
and so I go and I call and I go can I
get a haircut in there because it's in
the middle of the day because we have
this weird Sky smoke where like we're
free at 1pm and you know most Barbers
people come after work or at lunch so I
call and they're like yeah come on in
they're like come on in yeah and so I go
in and the old guy who's cut my son's
hair for forever is not available but
there's this young guy that works with
her and I'm like well he's his trainee
he's great and you know the old guys
with scissors and you know they're he's
talking to his friend who's reading an
Italian newspaper and I'm like I'm set
so I sit in the chair and the young guy
takes out you know like there's some
people that just cut hair with like a a
Tremors yeah yeah and so he starts my
barber Terrace all scissors yes and so
he starts cutting my hair but again I'm
like this is the it's it's a it's a it's
a hair cut place it's not a barber shop
but it's like this guy knows what he's
doing but the weird thing is it's like
my hair I don't have much of it left but
like you got plenty I got a nice
fleshyama but it grows out kind of like
this and so like
what you have to do is you have to kind
of cut underneath it I'm getting to a
point so then I'm trying to communicate
to this this to the guy I'm like you
know it's like my hair kind of
underneath here you have to trim it or
other I'll get like these clown ears
that clown edges and he goes yeah yeah
and just goes
and I'm like ah
uh but uh and I go that's not what I
said and so you'll see on my special
dark pale that my hair wait this is the
haircut you got this is that for the
special and so the hair the trainee I
look at you know
during the edit I'm just like
the hair and I'm like she's that hair
looks bad so you'll look at it
and I'm like good God it is forever too
and I was ridiculous yeah and so it's
just it you'll just see it and you'll go
guys now his hair looks like and it
does look like and that's literally
I got a haircut like four days before
and it was just a bad haircut
it's just because you told your great
story oh man that lady dyed my hair and
it turned out black as these microphones
man I was like yeah what are you doing
and do you want to dye your eyebrows no
I don't want to do that either and so by
the way so on I had a thing where
on uh
on the Jim Gaffigan show when I was
doing it because I have all right so I
have blonde hair but essentially when
blonde hair when you when you get old
essentially it doesn't turn gray it
turns white white yeah like Andy Warhol
white right and so what happens is in
acting projects
the Director of Photography is like you
gotta do something to your hair man it
just
it hits the light and and blonde hair is
really thin so the the light hits it you
know like you can do the Mike Pence
thing where it's really tight to your
head but if you have any hair standing
up it it's catches light and it kind of
flares so essentially this guy who was
the the Director of Photography on this
show uh the Jim Gaffigan show he's like
he goes I don't want to overstep my
boundaries but like your hair is like
it's like invisible it's like you just
gotta diet blonde which is doesn't seem
noticeable I'm like yeah yeah sure sure
and so I so we go my wife was the
showrunner and she goes to the hair
person she goes yeah we need to dye his
hair blonde and so this is similar to
your story so then the guys dyes my hair
and he dies it red
and so
it's kind of strawberry blonde and so I
don't know anything about like hair dye
or anything but apparently like
blonde is
type of uh it's a shade of red or
whatever and so
uh we did it and I was like this is kind
of red and he's like no it's not that's
blonde and so I got and so then I'm like
all right I'm dumb so maybe it is
maybe it is
blonde but I see red so then I go out
and I show my wife and she goes your
hair is red like he just said so then we
go back in we're like it's red and he
goes it's blonde and they're like so
we're like all right fine it's red it's
blonde but can you make it more blonde
so he does it again and I don't know if
you've had your hair dye it's like your
skulls like stinging from this die and
so then it's essentially it's still
strawberry blonde we just reinforced
what this guy views as blonde and so on
my IMDb page
you know like they have characteristics
you know like it would be and and one of
them it says strawberry blonde hair when
I don't have strawberries
it's just like
in this blonde my entire life is called
champagne blonde no I've been this but I
just thought that was funny because it's
you know not only we've all gotten bad
haircuts and we've all you know people
with the best intentions will mess up
but like
now it was like a characteristic you
know his pale skin with his strawberry
blonde hair and like strawberry blonde
so specific so stupid
um I want to go back to talking about
your mom for a second yeah
um so ovarian cancer I'm assuming you
guys that was a slow uh thing and not
sudden did you yeah did you were you
able to see your mom were you still
there at the time yeah I was I was
living in New York it's before I had
started stand up
um
but I remember uh
you know there was something about I
mean I was kind of such a
uh so it was you know my family's not
good at processing things like that so
we would talk but it was
I remember when I because I graduated
from college and I moved to where'd you
graduate I went to Georgetown oh wow
dude damn hell yeah would I hold you at
the table but are you there when Ewing
was there I was you were transferred in
I transferred in I by the way that's the
school my dad went to my dad went to
Georgetown my older brother my kind of
Irish twin went to Georgetown
I had a after buttons died we got
eventually we got another dog that dog
was named Toya
I had always wanted to go to Georgetown
I applied didn't get in
so it was like not only did I not get in
I had a dog named Toya and so two
relatives and so it was giving you all
money yeah it was it was pretty but that
kind of rejection that appetite
because I think the entertainment
industry is about
it's not just about how you handle
success it's how you handle the constant
humiliation and if you don't have a bit
of an appetite
for
you're gonna have a hard time use amen
dear I mean and so so real quick you
where did you go first what college
Purdue all right so you want the full-on
Purdue not IUPUI Purdue all right but
you know by the way uh so I apply into
all these colleges
didn't get in got wait listed at some of
them
but back then in
1987 at that time you could apply to
Purdue by submitting a postcard because
I was an Indiana resident I see and it
was I just submitted the postcard and I
got in so now why transfer into
Georgetown was it a you because you
really wanted to do it was it one of
those things you thought you should
because Dad and brother had done no it
was it was definitely she could have
gone anywhere it was def I knew that I
wanted to get to the East Coast I mean I
loved Indiana but
I think when I was a teenager I didn't
love I mean I love Indiana now but like
as a teenager I was like I there's a
there's been a mistake I'm not supposed
to be here like I would look around I
had a friend of mine who now lives in
Maine who uh we used to talk about like
there was some kind of
disaster you know that we ended up here
and so then of course I eventually get
to New York City after all this stuff
and I'm like I made it to New York and
and everyone in New York's like you're
the most Midwestern looking person I've
ever seen you're like it's a strawberry
blonde hair I was like so it was like
but I think a lot of comedians that is
or you know they're constantly
struggling with identity in some ways
like they're trying to either
um
uh you know it's a cranking of a dial on
the identity it's either
you know like we were talking before
it's like I love David tell but it's
like you'd think like if you know David
tell you'd think what is this guy is he
from the 30s did he grow up with the
Bowery Boys it's like he came from a
nice community on Long Island he's he's
authentic
but like some of it is there's different
identities of comedians you know I mean
like they Crank It Up or they crank it
down you know what I mean and some of it
is it's thrust upon you so in other
words I you know the reason I'm uh you
know people are like you're the most
Midwestern person in the world is
because I look Midwestern and so when I
would go on stage in in New York City in
the early 90s all these comedians would
go on stage and be like my mother's
Jewish my father's Italian you know and
so when I got on stage I was like I I
was like I I'm white and I'm white and
uh there's you know I'm Irish but like
not really you know I mean so there was
my ethnic identity was Midwestern or you
know
trash you know what I mean are there any
um conversations that you have with your
mom that still stick with you or stand
out before she passed
oh yeah no there's uh anything she said
to you any advice or anything she even
just said to you anything she admitted
to you or told you
did you get one-on-ones or six of you
yeah no there was plenty of time
um I mean never enough time but like
there was definitely conversations and
then by the way then there's
you know I don't know if you you know
anyone who's lost someone uh through
like say uh you know a losing battle
with cancer and they're on pain
medication
what they're saying on pain medication
you kind of
sometimes give that a weight that you
shouldn't do I mean yeah so we are like
uh is she talking about Saturday Night
Live to me
or did she just do is it Sunday and she
was watching it last night so but for me
it was
I think my mother was somebody there was
the she was the one person in my life
that was
uh I had no doubt about her
love and support and you know some of it
is like
you know uh my dad you know there was a
bit of combativeness with my dad he was
a you know there was a fatigue
you know he had six kids he's like what
the yeah I mean I another one yeah
and so like there was uh
and he was of a different era I describe
him as uh the pre-fildanahu era do I
mean like it was Phil kicked all that
talk show stuff yeah you know I mean
like he was like
you know and he was a a compassionate
guy and he was you know Progressive for
his era but he was like definitely like
I'm not making dinner
yes yes I'm not yeah I brought the money
out yeah you know I mean I'm not you
know the chaos is you know and he wasn't
you know again for his era he was like
very much uh you know he ended up
running this Bank in Northwest Indiana
and he made a point of making sure like
hiring the first vice president that was
African-American and people were not
thrilled about it but he also did that
and he did it in a way where it was like
uh he knew it was important you know
what I mean so like I do give him credit
for but there was also other stuff where
he was just like
you know
just really set in his ways and uh was
he older than your mom about the same
age a couple years older yeah a couple
years older
how how did he change when your mom
passed oh I mean he was
I mean I think that he was like was he a
little lost he was a little lost he
ended up getting remarried but you have
to understand my dad was and I thought
you know growing up you think all your
parents do that all parents do this but
like
my dad would come home
and
have a vodka
and uh on the rocks
and then he would switch to Scotch at a
certain point of the evening yeah and I
remember thinking because half the times
I would be like all right I'm trying to
bring dad a scotch you know what I mean
and
you know like
I
if I have like so he would over the
course of the night and at minimum three
or four drinks like if I had four drinks
in a night I would be
like a mess for a couple days
and he was just fine like there that
generation knew how to put it away yeah
but also it's just like I I think of
like
sheer amount of money wasted yeah yeah
right do you know what I mean yeah it's
just so like there is
and it was just like a different era it
was like before
um Mothers Against Drunk Driving yes I
Felts all that stuff it was you could
use it and drive you could do it yeah he
was like he was in a drunk driving
accident he's like that sorry
and it wasn't like one there was no
public shame right yeah yeah it was just
like hey or yeah yeah it was just and
then later on he
you know I think he he stopped he tried
he stopped drinking he you know he went
to AAA but then when he you know got
sick he's like if I'm out I'm gonna have
some cocktails so like when he knew he
was uh dying he went back to it no yeah
he said it so he knew what did he
get cancer as well yeah I mean but these
I mean my parents were always assuming
he was 63. still young but yeah but he
was you know he was consuming at least
two packs a day cigarettes and alcohol
three drinks and two packs of just like
it was you know it was a a sheer amount
of and he also when my mom died he
you know like growing up poor he you
know steak was such a
you know like you would have it on
special occasions
so and he would uh we would have steak
maybe once a week but like when my mom
died he's like steak every night yeah
we're having steak every night and I'm
like
all right
you know what I mean but yeah the so
when he got the news he was like I'm
going back to drinking why not yes he
was like I'm done I gotta say I think I
would too though you know what I mean if
you if you know unless they're like hey
we were wrong you're like oh yeah
well it's awesome
cancer is gone yeah it was also one of
those things where it was I think it was
lung cancer and cancer that was gonna
get to the brain it was
yeah
so but I think in my family
how old are you now I'm 57. I know you
this isn't that insane it is insane
um are you staying I'm 50. but my father
died at 42 and it was very weird when I
hit 42 because I actually almost I
clotted then and almost died at 42. is a
same situation but I made it and then
now I still feel I don't think I don't
care if I live through 103 I'm never
gonna feel older than my dad does that
make any sense like I know I've
lived eight years longer than that man
did on this planet but anytime I think
of him I still think of him as an elder
you know what I mean he's dead yeah
senior figure I don't
it's so crazy because I think also in my
family like I grew up
maybe to the age of I think my one my my
grandmother died when I was
10.
but when I was born the three other ones
were already dead like in my family
people go out early yeah and some of it
I think is the the partying yeah I've
been watching your health are you at the
doctors all you look great I mean no but
thank you I mean
but but not
you're not getting your yearly physical
you're doing it I'm doing I'm doing that
yeah but like I also
and I don't know how I dodged this but
like I have a very addictive personality
which is
and I you know but my addictions
you know it's like food nicotine gum I'm
addicted to but like you used to smoke I
did oh you did my girl you did yeah so
I'm addicted to the gum but like it's
you know I'm 20 years on the gum are you
really yeah and so could you stop the
gum
I just need to be chewing you know what
I mean so I uh
yeah no I mean it is a compulsive you
know it is
but so yeah so like but I'm so thrilled
that I dodged
of the booze you know what I mean like
the booze is just like if you look at my
family history it's like
it's it you know it takes people out
early you know what I mean so I think
and you know it also you know obviously
it could be any drug right
and so it's terrifying having kids
because I'm trying to communicate them
I'm like
I was told I was corrected this weekend
in Appleton Wisconsin by a doctor I
always say Fentanyl and he said it's
actually fentanyl oh really like NyQuil
not like Tylenol I said all right I'll
try to start saying it right but I keep
hearing fentanyl fentanyl everywhere but
that's what scares me I've my daughter's
eight and we see it on the sides of
buses and a good friend of ours daughter
was uh died from it so there's been no
hiding you'd asked me earlier too if my
daughter knew I smoked cannabis or
anything and she does after the hospital
stuff and they told me that's all I was
allowed to do yeah I sat her down I was
like listen you're about to get an
educational marijuana that no one in
your class is probably going to get and
I recorded the surgeons talking about
how it's met I could be used as medicine
and everything and I was like these are
the doctors saying this so people don't
you know if you ever say anything about
your dad and they're like he's a loser
for smoking wheat whatever it is you
know the truth over here so oh wow
that's brilliant yeah I've played that
for her and let her listen to that and
um
you know this there was no way to hide
it she said what happened to your
friend's daughter and I was like you
know what we were driving back from
Ocean City Maryland to Philly because we
flew into Philly yeah and um I was like
we're gonna have a real adult
conversation and now we're seeing it on
the sides of buses on the way to school
and everything so I'm I don't care that
it's a little early I'm trying to
educate her on that because I would be
devastated if it tended she ate a gummy
or some that was laced and then
yeah but you know that's terrifying
that's what's crazy is that
I mean I think that it is because my
kids are 10 to 19. and
it you know there is uh you know and my
kids you know I live in New York City
but
there is something about
what's happening because I think it's
even scarier let me bring up this scary
fact please is that
they're you know since these kids that
are dying from it
there's
shock and shame and so you know as your
daughter gets you only have one cat yeah
her brother's my stepson but okay and so
like because what happens in when a kid
gets older is that essentially in high
school or in middle school there will be
an email that will go out and say so and
so uh the it's uh the tragic loss of so
and so uh you know someone in a
different grade someone sibling of
someone that goes to school and you'll
realize later on sometimes it was
suicide sometimes it was
um uh you know some fentanyl related
thing and what's terrifying is that
unders and you can understand the logic
of it these families are devastating
like there was a a kid in New York City
that
where the parents were the kid had
gotten into Notre Dame
and he you know I think he was a partier
and he had
um
he was they were kind of celebrating you
know there were with some friends that
kind of like a weed pen or whatever it
wasn't even his weed pen
that he was like let me have a head of
that and he took ahead of it
and then he for and I don't know all the
details jumped off a building what yes
and so the thing is is that so like this
kid was going to Notre Dame this kid was
not a up
the kid who had the pen
and gave the pen from what I understand
was not a up he was kind of like
I'm a senior in high school I've kicked
ass I'm going to get a pet you can get
it so easily in New York City which is a
problem because of course among
comedians we you know I spent the last
20 years doing these benefits on
legalizing pot and stuff like that so
the problem is is like I think in La
they enforce it a lot more but in New
York it's just decriminalized and so
like there's essentially it's the wild
west but what happens is so this family
that lost this son
the only reason we know about it is a
friend of a friend but otherwise
they don't want to go to the
police
they don't want the friend
they didn't want them to get in trouble
so what happens is
it's not reported it's not like a gun
death right it's not like
um
you know
um you know where they're on math and
they're living in an abandoned house
it's they are these pretty normal kids
that whereas like when we were growing
up we might have gotten we might have
drank some
uh some kind of really cheap beer that
was warm and gotten buzzed they're
getting exposed to like this laced pot
that will kill them that will kill them
and but I think the fascinating thing is
these parents the in their grief
you know it's not like the you know
their kid was
shot at Newtown or whatever it was
it was is this because teenagers make
dumb mistakes we all did right listen if
I was a teenager and these vape pens
were around I definitely would smoke
them I'd be an idiot we had we had
cigarettes and I smoked cigarettes my
our doctor
and you know some of it is I this sounds
like an exaggeration but I didn't
realize the vape pens we talked a little
bit the vape pens and again I have a
highly addictive personality and but
like because you're inhaling oil
it destroys your lungs so like there's
these kids that have been vaping since
the age of 12 and then by the time
they're 20 they need a lung transplant
popcorn lung some of that stuff they
call it pop this is what I learned about
in the hospital because I was like okay
am I done with cannabis and they were
like you can have cannabis I just choose
not to smoke the infused stuff because
it just makes me cough so much more
um they told me no Vapes tobacco or THC
like none
um no alcohol because of the blood
thinners but no tobacco products no
cigars no blunt wraps none of that stuff
because it's just so much you know
there's so many toxins in all that it's
just the chemicals right yeah
um I want to ask you this before we wrap
up two questions
um one is how do you
um keep your parents alive with your
children like do you tell stories do you
have photos around the house
um
you know what do you do I I I know I
have pictures around I tell my daughter
stories all the time like oh you're
especially if she's busting my chops
I'll be like no your grandfather would
actually join in on that with you for
sure yeah the uh yeah you know that's
really interesting because there is part
of me that is
my family culture was very much like
don't talk about it and
don't uh you know uh unnecessary
emotion is
um
you know it's kind it's like these these
Midwestern Catholics aspired so much to
be waspy that they're kind of like don't
deal with emotions yeah I mean yeah and
so but to answer your question I mean my
daughter my oldest daughter is named
after my mom that's nice and um and then
my son Michael's named after uh he's
named after the Archangel but also my
father's name was Michael and my I have
a brother named Michael but yeah it's
it's weird because I feel like I should
talk about it but it's not
part of our family culture and it should
and I I regret kind of not having
discussions I mean but my sons did
during the pandemic there was
you know when everyone was on lockdown
there was some kind of needlepoint
assignment and I explained to my kids
that my mom
won some Neil Point aside so like there
is family lore that I'll bring up but
probably not enough probably not enough
and some of it is just
that's I think in my family it's
perceived as ah bragging I don't know
it's weird it's so funny my daughter
says that to me I'm like did you tell
your friends that you did this in the
camp or or in summer because she was
like I can't dad that's bragging I'm
like is that how everybody looks at is
that brag it just telling somebody I
went to this
again well you know there is something
by the way I mean I think that
I mean one of the great gifts uh my
mother gave me that and you know my 12
year old son is pretty good at
basketball
and
but like the the family culture of like
never bragging and never
you know
never gloating is like something that I
uh my mom kind of reinforced and then I
see myself
uh doing that with him I'm like yeah if
you are good that's good but like you
don't gloat act like you've been there
you know I mean and you there's no need
to show emotion you have the joy inside
you if you make a basket you don't need
to rub it in
you know you have to manage these things
and it's like if you see other kids
doing that that's fine but like
you don't do that I remember
um Walter Payton before he passed his
son played at University of Miami he was
a running back and he scored he got in a
touchdown in the end zone he started
dancing and all that and he said he
heard this whistle
from up in the bleachers and he looked
up and it's his dad Walter Payton he
just went like this
uh-uh we don't do that and he said
never again never again I didn't think
you go back to even do that you go back
and watch old footage of Walter Payton
it was just flip the ball to the ref you
know after one of the most amazing runs
you've ever seen just act like you've
been there before We're not gonna dance
and all that stuff yeah you know
um all right last question okay um after
everything we've talked about today I
always ask the guest their first time
here advice you would give to your 16
year old self what would you tell 16
year old Jim Gaffigan wow
I
yeah I mean there's so much I mean I've
been through like
eight different lives but I would say uh
there's gonna be some ups and downs
but uh it's you're gonna learn from
every kind of crisis
do you know what I mean and that
uh
the you know the humility that you kind
of
uh and hard work you approach things
with
is be gonna be valuable
do you remember because I think that's
one of the things that
I you know I was one of those students
that like I had to work really hard to
get a B plus yeah me too you know I mean
and it's like it was frustrating because
a lot of kids things just came naturally
to them
and so things are harder
um but that's not to say that I don't
have you know I didn't have privileges
or whatever but like
um
that some of those disappointments
like that that Devastation of not
getting in a Georgetown or the
humiliation of those first
nine years of doing stand up
were
in a way a gift
right I know that sounds corny like it's
100 I think about all these bad things
and then where you are on the other side
I'm like I guess I kind of had to happen
yeah and it's like if you can be a
decent person about it it's like how you
hate you know because I feel like when
there's big crisis like even when the
lockdown happened
uh and you know we you know I mean now
we know it was nothing but like I mean
it wasn't nothing but it was but it was
like
I wasn't freaking out I was like all
right dear I mean like yeah like there
is like the more high stress situation
I'm in and I don't know if this has to
do with sports but I'm like
I don't get thrown by it I that's not to
say that I'm not aware of the stress of
the situation but
I'll get more angry at somebody cutting
me off driving somewhere than I am of
like oh all right I just lost a hundred
thousand dollars
I mean I'm not like somebody like ah
there's a bit of world disaster that's
happened I'm like all right you know and
when my kids mess up they I think they
know they can come to me I'm like all
right
it's pretty bad you know but we'll uh
we'll we'll get through this you know I
mean and so uh that's where I would say
that
the punishment of life is some lessons
right yeah that's great I can't tell you
enough how excited I was to have you on
here thank you for doing this please
plug everything again oh well you know
I've got the Amazon special that's uh on
Prime if you have Amazon account you you
probably have Prime
um and then I'm in this uh
uh Max
streaming show called Full Circle which
is if you have Max and then
I'm on tour always coming up with new
material I love it and I'm doing a
handful of shows with Seinfeld which is
surreal that is crazy right there
together that's not it's just but he's
also I mean comedians the relationship
comedians have
is
it's weird because it's
like the shorthand the the praise and
the amount of that we've eaten
and uh talking about comedy they're the
like-mindedness it's
you know it's not like
you know we
you know I jokingly say well I wanted to
help out Jerry Jerry Seinfeld it's much
more of like
I'm excited because after the shows I
get to pick his brain on stand up you
know what I mean yeah and comedy in
general because he is kind of this
Aristotle figure on Comedy that
he has somehow he has like a zen-like
approach to it where he removes emotion
whereas I think that we're all kind of
comedy's weird because you have to take
things personally to have a point of
view but if you take things too
personally then you're you're raging
Against the Machine and not doing the
job
so great thank you so much uh as always
Ryan sickler on all social media come
see me on tour all tickets available
Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign